[Musique]
pousaz énergie ça nous est arrivé à
thatcher sur ma voisine de derrière qui
me dit que révèle toiture je me réveille
je crois que j'avais plancher les
portables les ordinateurs des enfants
comme on voit la montre et l'aria les
ordinateurs avant qu'ils sont plus en
valeur l'eau avait tout envahi new
castle est perçu comme vous pourrez le
monde où le thème être passé sur ce mois
[Musique]
non
mais ce qu'on remarque ici c'est d'abord
les déchets beaucoup plus de déchets
plastiques parce que les populations
riveraines
transforme secours dans un dépotoir
pratique malheureusement un deuxième
phénomène de phénomène d'envasement
nouvellement d'envasement et puis la
colonisation
de la chiffa de l'opa des plantes
envahissantes
ces trois phénomènes réduisent
émargement le lit le lit de l'eau et
l'eau cyanotype le lot obligé de
déborder de quitter nos lits évidemment
pour gagner pour gagner les maisons
[Musique]
le